yeah it's very hip to be spiritual but
not religious almost everybody I know
says they're spiritual now that's good
I mean spiritual is good spiritual means
that you have a relationship with God
spiritual means that you you connect
with God that spirituality is an
important part of your life you try to
lead a good life you try to be in
concert with what your relationship with
God tells you which is terrific I mean
you have to have that religious on the
other hand in current parlance is bad
because that seems to say that oh I
believe in this organization that has
all these hidebound dogmas and beliefs
and I would never be able to belong to
an organization that tells me what to
think things like that the problem with
being spiritual but not religious is
that you're not part of a community in a
sense and so there's no one to sort of
bump up against to tell you when you
might be a little off track as well
you're not really able to connect in
your spiritual life with other people
there was a great saying from Isaac
Hecker who was a 19th century American
priest and he said religion enables us
to connect and correct so we connect
with other people we're naturally social
animals right and we like to worship in
common that makes sense we connect with
one another and we're corrected I mean
you know if I have a direct line to God
right that means that by definition
anything I think or say is from God
right and that's as we know a problem
so being spiritual without being
religious means that you're lacking kind
of the wisdom of the community you know
as well as the support of the community
you know when you're when you're sort of
struggling being religious without being
spiritual is just as bad being religious
without being spiritual just means all
you're doing is following the rules
you're just following the rules you're
just listening to the community and
you're not reflecting on things yourself
so the one thing is what Jesus was
warning against being religious without
being spiritual you know did some of the
religious authorities of his day when
I'm warning against is being spiritual
without being religious which is much
more common today so I think it's not an
either/or I think it's about